ماسك يا تراجع خطوه ويعيد بعض الموظفين
المفصولين وعريس الاسماعيليه الى السجن
بامر القضاء اهلا بكم
خلينا نبتدي مع وقفتنا اليوم مع اخبار
تويتر
بتنفيذ الاشتراك بالعلامه الزرقاء في عدد
من الدول واستعرضنا التطورات في الموضوع
لكن اللي صار انه صحيفه نيويورك
مفادو انه تويتر راح ياجل البدء بتنفيذ
الاشتراك في علامه التوثيق لغايه الامتحان
من الانتخابات النصفيه يوم الثلاثاء وهذه
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه حتى حدد لي
من الكافه
الديمقراطيين ولا الجمهوريين فعلشان ما
يصير لاعب وتؤدي لخبطه في الانتخابات تم
تاجيل قرار تفعيل الاشتراك في العلامه
الزرقاء لغايه ما تخلص الانتخابات اشتراك
العلامه اتاجل لكن في شيء لغى هو تسريح
عشرات من الموظفين ففي مصادر خاصه من داخل
شركه تويتر قالت لي بلوك انه تويتر طلب من
بعض الموظ اللي تم تسريحهم بالخطا يوم
الجمعه العوده الى عملهم لانه تبين بعدين
انه في اشخاص تم تسريحهم من عملهم من دون
ما يطلعوا على خبراتهم في العمل وقدرات
وملكتشفوا انها ضروري
للميزات اللي ماسك ناوي يزود تويتر فيها
لذلك قررت الشركه انها ترجعهم للعمل وطبعا
شركه وترك كانت سرحت يوم الجمعه 50% من
الموظفيها ومع هذه القرارات ال الماسك
المستمر في نشاطه على تويتر فال تغريدات
متوجبت وهو جالس يشرح التويتر راح يكون
المنصه الاكثر مصداقيه ودقه في العالم
وتابعنا نشره تحديثات اللي بيعملها في
المنصه وهذه المره في سياستها فاعلن انه
راح يوافق كل الحسابات اللي بتقلد
المشاهير بطريقه ساخره من دون ما تعلن
وتحدث انه هذا الحساب هو حساب محاك ساخر
وكمان اعلن انه اي ريوزال راح يتم تغييره
راح يخسر علامه الزرقاء مؤقتا لحين التحقق
من الحساب واكد انه في السابق كان تويتر
بيبعث رسائل تحذير قبل تعليق الحساب اما
السياسه الجديده لتويتر فما فيها رسائل
تحذير ابدا وبيتم تعليق الحساب مباشره
وعلى فكره من بعد ما اتكلم ماسك عن هذه
السياسه الجديده وانتحال الهويه الصحفي بن
بن جون سنتكلم عن محاوله الممثله
الامريكيه كاتي جريفن بانها تعمل حساب
باسم الماسك ونشر تغريده وصوره او هو نشر
تحديدا تغريده وصوره بتبين انه تم تعليق
الحساب بشكل كامل وكتب في تغيير الثانيه
انه هذا الشيء صار من بعد ما تم الاعلان
على او عن سياسه التحقق من منتحلي الشخصيه
وضعنا في الاستديو احمد الشيخ المتخصص في
المنصات الاجتماعيه اهلا فيك معنا كثير
تغيرات جلسه بتصير بشكل يومي كل ساعه
عندنا تغيير جديد الان بعد ما كان جالس
بيقول هتدفع وهتدفع حتدفعوا رجع قال حناجل
الموضوع عشان الانتخابات النصفيه
الانتخابات النصفيه
تراجع هو تراجع في مساله البلوتشيك او
التحقق من العلامه الزرقاء وايضا تراجع في
مساله الموظفين مساله التاجيل لما بعد
الانتخابات النصفيه هو مجرد حجه هو طبعا
شايف ان الاوضاع دلوقت غير مستقره وغير
مهيئه لفرد هذا الاجراء في مشكله كبيره في
هذا الاجراء هي فكره منتحلي الشخصيه اللي
كانت بتتكلم عنها في اطار اخر دلوقتي
تويتر المفروض هي اللي هتحقق في شخصيات
الناس المشكله دلوقتي ان اللي عنده علامه
زرقاء ده هو شخص معروف
ممثل مغني ما حدش سياسي متحدث رسمي شخص
معروف وبالتالي لو في حد انتحل شخصيته
الناس هتعرف وهتبلغ تويتر ولكن لو في حد
قدم نفسه بصفته محمد احمد وقدم باسبور
بصفه محمد احمد وبدا يحتال على الناس او
يعمل اي حاجه مخالفه للقوانين على تويتر
تحت اسم محمد احمد وهو واخد العلامه
الزرقاء طيب مين هيتحمل المسؤوليه فيها
هذه اللحظه هل هو الشخص اللي احنا مش
عارفينه ولا هو تويتر وهل تويتر يعني
يمتلك ال- ال- الريسورز او الامكانيات
عشان يحقق الشخصيات ده في ناس بتتحيل على
انظمه الهجره وبيزوره بسبوراته
فعلشان كده قالوا ماسك وتويتر شاف ان
المساله كبيره جدا احباب للاحتيال
والاجرام تحت الستار العلامه الزرقاء
وبالتالي كان لابد ان يتراجع ولو مؤقته
يعني الموضوع انت بتقول انه مش بس
للانتخابات والتلاعب في الانتخابات هو
السبب في هذا كان مجرد عنوان يعني طب بس
الانتخابات الان هتكون يعني
هو مجمدها يعني فتره قصيره يعني لازم
يلاقي حل سريعا بالضبط وداي يؤكد ان
الانتخابات ليست هي السبب الوحيد في في
اسباب اخرى طبعا مساله للانتخابات هي اللي
تكلمت عنها بلومبيرغ ولكن في مصادر اخرى
بتتكلم عن التحديات الاخرى يومين
والانتخابات هتخلص وبالتالي لهم ماسك لازم
يلاقي حل اخر في يعني في تحديات كبيره
بتواجه مساله العلامه الزرقاء خصوصا من
المشاهير لان المشاهير شايفين ان اي احد
دلوقت هيبقى عنده علامه زرقاء وبالتالي هي
فقدت قيمتها هو في الاول كان واخد العلامه
الزرقاء باعتبار ان هو شخصيه عامه دلوقت
تويتر في في بياناته الرسميه وحتى على ابل
بيقول للناس انت مش لازم تكون شخصيه عامه
علشان تاخذ علامه زرقاء بس الثمانيه دولار
اذا فهي كده فقدت قيمتها وفي ناس كثير جدا
بيقولوا خلاص مش هندفع ومش عايزين العلامه
الزرقاء لان هي كده فقدت قيمتها همم
بس الموضوع الوحيد ان احنا بنتكلم كمان عن
تسريحه الموظفين واعاده بعض الموظفين انه
لا تعالوا انتم انفصلتوا بال هذا النوع من
التضارب يعني كيف الواحد يقدر يفسر ظهوره
من شخص زي قال ماسك متمرس في الاداره شخص
ذكي جدا كل هذا الكلام كيف يعمل هذه
التناقضات قالوا ماسك دلوقتي يعني بيدير
المعركه بعده وسائل او او مدفوعه عن بعده
دوافع هو عنده دلوقتي هو بيستعين بمين هو
بيستعين بعده شخصيات بعضها من تويتر
وبعضها من خارج تويتر من شركاته الاخرى من
تيسلا وسبيس اكس وغيرها والمفروض ان اهل
تويتر همم يعني ادرى بشعبها يعني
هو جاب ناس ثانيه من بره يعني واضح ان هي
لخبطت الموضوع اكتر احد الموظفين كان كاتب
بيقول ان هو سال المدير بتاعه او سور
المدير بتاعه قال له لو جاء لك ايميلات
خلال الفتره الجايه فانت معنا لو ما جالكش
يبقى انت مرفود اذا المديرين نفسهم ما
كانوش عارفين مين اللي قاعد ومين اللي
ماشي المساله تمت يعني يلا يلا نتخلص يلا
نتخلص من اللي بيتعاملوا مع مسائل كذا
وكذا وكذا ده بيحصل يعني الناس طبعا
استغربا ده يحصل في مؤسسه كبيره ولكن في
مؤسسات كبيره جدا مترهله وفيها اخطاء
كبيره وبتحصل فيها بلاوي وبيوصلوا للمحاكم
يعني وبالتالي فده ممكن يحصل في مؤسسه زي
تويتر ويحصل في مؤسسه من مؤسسات الى
الماسك اي لون ماسك كمان واضح انه بيدير
المساله بشكل شخصي يعني شوفي حجم التويتس
اللي بيكتبها كل يوم يعني ده احنا انا
وانت ما عندناش وقت نكتب كل هذه التويتس
ما حدش فينا بيكتب هذا العالم
في اغنى رجل في العالم بيكتب كل هذه
التويتس ده ده برده
تحليل نفسي لاحد المحللين نفسيين
الامريكان قال ان قالوا ماسك بيهرب الى
هذه التغريدات هو عنده حاجات اخرى حاجات
اخرى بتشغله بتشغله نفسيا وصحيه ومليا وكل
حاجه هو بيهرب الى التغريد لانه الماسك
برده عنده استراتيجيه مهمه جدا ودي
بيتبعها دائما ان هو يتصدر عناوين الاخبار
بالحق والباطل في 2018 قال لي الناس انا
هاعمل الغواصه اللي هتروح تايلاند تنقذ
الاطفال من الك صح شفنا غواصه ولا شوفنا
له الماسك ساعتها اختفى هو والغواصه
بتاعته ما حصلتش قال للناس هاعمل لكم
شريحه بدل المنسف مثلا
عليها
زي الصواريخ اللي هو عملها فعلا ولا
مصيرها زي الغواصه احنا لسه مش عارفين
المستقبل بس هو لما بيغرد التغريدات هذه
كلها هذه كلها فيها وعود يعني يعني اشياء
ممكن بسهوله الناس ترجع تقول له اه هذه
تغريدتك اتفضل انت قلت كده يعني فاكيد هو
عامل حسابه يتراجع عن كلامه وعن تغريداته
يعني لو لو تطلعنا على وثائق المحكمه وهي
متاحه دلوقت على الانترنت المحكمه اللي
كان المفروض تنطلق يوم 17/10 هنلاقي اثبات
حذف رسائل خاصه كان بيتبادل الرسائل مع
المسؤولين بتوع تويتر ومع المسؤولين عن
اداره الصفقه ولكن حذف هذه الرسائل ده
يلزم نفسه ولكن خلاص ال- ال- الطرف الثاني
كان عارف هذه الرسائل
محكمه اثبتت انه يتهرب من التزاماته
وبالتالي اي وعد هياخذوا الى الماسك على
نفسه هو غير ملزم به عادي ممكن اتراجع عنه
بالضبط طيب يعني مذهل هذا الموضوع واحنا
لسه هنشوف كثير بنشكرك على وجودك معنا كان
معنا في الاستديو احمد الشيخ المتخصص في
المنصات الاجتماعيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد عروس الاسماعيليه مها محمد
اللي شغلت الراي العام العربي والمصري
بسبب تعنيف زوجها لها الناس متابعه تطورات
قصتها من البدايه وتحديدا من بعد ما انتشر
مقطع فيديو لها وهي بتتعرض للضرب من زوجها
في الشارع يوم الفرح ومن بعدها طلعت هي
وزوجها وقالوا انه اللي صار سوء تفاهم
بينهم وانتهت القصه بعد ثمانيه اشهر
اتفاجا الناس بفيديو لها وهي بتستغيث
بالشرطه وبتقول انه ضربها واحتجازها 15
يوم في منزل اخوه ورفعت عليه قضيه وبدات
جلسات المحاكمه اليوم انتهت الجلسه
الثالثه والاخيره للمحاكمه والمحكمه قضت
على عريس الاسماعيليه عبد الله محمود
بالسجن لمده سنه مع الشغل والنفاذ وتعويض
قدره 2000 جنيه لزوجته مها محمد
المنتخب سنه
المصاريف المدنيه ثانيا ببراءه المتهم من
تهمه احتجاز المدعيه بالحق المدني مها
محمد عمران محمد اتهام الاول رفعت الجزمه
وتنضم الينا من القاهره فريده الشوباشي
عضو البرلمان المصري اهلا فيك معنا من اول
شيء طبعا اكيد حضرتك تبعتي القصه ايش رايك
في العقوبه انه سنه مع الشغل والنفاذ و
2000 جنيه تعويض
نعم يعني انا طبعا بعتبر ان الامر امام
القضاء يبقى في كل التفاصيل احنا ما
عندناش كل التفاصيل
ومجرد الاذان هنا والحبس فهذا اول مره
يحصل نوع من الردع للرجال اللي بيعتدوا
على زوجاتهم بالضرب يعني انا مش فاهمه زي
ممكن واحد يتصور
انسانه تعيش معه بعد ما يهينها بانه
يضربها لان الضرب ده اخر حاجه يعني اخر
حاجه الواحد بيرجع لها ولو ما قدرش يوصل
لها لا هو مش اخر حاجه هو ما المفروض يعني
يوصل لها اصلا
خلينا نكون متفقين يعني طبعا ما انا باقول
اخر ولا يوصلك اخر حاجه يوصل لها
ما هو لو ضربها بقى يبقى ما فيش حياه
مشتركه بعد كده اوكي ده اللي انا بقوله
يعني يعني لو واحد يتصور ان بعد ما يضرب
مراته هترجع له كمان وتبقى عاديه معه يبقى
عنده اختلال ولكن هذا اللي حصل هذا اللي
حصل هو ضربها ويوم الفرح ومقطع موثق وما
الى ذلك ويرجعك وبعدين قال لما تركها صارت
الناس تقول انه همم اللي يضرب مره يضرب
اكثر من مره وما له ذلك يعني همم كان في
تناقضات كثير في هذه القصه
بالضبط كده هو استغل هذه الترددات وانا
طبعا الوم عليها برده لان لو يوم الفرح
ضربها كان حقها سابتهم الفرح يعني وكنت
بقت الفرحه انها اكتشفت هو ايه بالضبط
انا ما بقدرش اتصور ان واحده تعيش مع واحد
ضربها
يعني ازاي يعني ازاي بعد كده يدومهم فراش
واحد ويضموه منزل واحد ودموهم اا مصير
مشترك واولاد مشتركه لا ما ينفعش يعني
يعني
على فكره عجز كمان ايوه وحضرتك يعني نمتي
عليه هو ولومتي عليها هو هي هي قبلت بس
كمان كان في منظومه سواء مثلا من الاهل او
حتى شفنا بعض الناس على التلفزيون طلعوا
تكلموا وقالوا يا جماعه هدوا النفوس خلوهم
يعني انه نوفق بينهم والطلاق ده امر مش
كويس فالموضوع يعني اجتماعي افضل
شوفي هي قالت لنا دلوقت بعد الفتاوي بتاعه
بعض الشيوخ او يعني المدعي ان هم شيوخ
اللي بيتكلموا عن ضرب المراه على فكره
ربنا كرم المراه ربنا كرم المراه تكريم لا
مثيل له ولا حاجه تعالوا الى مستواه يعني
انه اودع فيه الرحم او ده فيها الرحم هل
ستتوها بالحياه يعني ما فيش عظيم في
العالم ممكن ان يكون له وجود لو لم تلدهم
امراه اظن دي ما فيهاش مناقشه
يعني الانبياء والرسل والزعماء وكله
المراه هي اللي ولدتهم فربنا كرمها انت
تيجي تضربها عشان ما اتفقتش معك في حاجه
يعني ما اتصلتش الاوامر سيادتك يعني ازاي
يعني انا ضد حكايه الضرب دي خالص يعني طيب
قانونيه
بس انه قانونيا هل نحن بنتكلم انه بشكل
عام في عقوبات رادعه ولا حضرتك تشعري انه
لابد من مثلا فرض المزيد من العقوبات على
هذا الموضوع موضوع تعني في المراه
لا انا انا رايي انه يعني نوع العقوبه
بيقدروا القاضي واحنا قضائنا قضاء محترم
يعني
التشريعات بقى يعني انا في مجلس النواب
اعتقد انه هيبقى في مطالبه بتشريعات قويه
او اقوى من كده علشان يبقى نوع من الردع
مش معقول الفوضى اللي بقينا فيها ان كل
واحد مش- شوفي
الجدع اللي قتل واحده عشان ما رضيتش
تتجوزه مثلا هو في ايه يعني
هذا مش شخص واحد هذه اصبحت ظاهر الحقيقه
بالضبط
تحقير المراه
والتقليل من شانها والتقليل من مكانتها
يعني هو ده هي دي الحاجه الكارثيه اللي
انا عايشها دلوقت لان انا كبيره قوي في
السن واا كنت عشت قبل كده قبل فتره
السبعينات
ال- ال- الخطاب ال- اللجان من بعض الناس
همم وما فيش كلام دلوقتي خالص اللي على عن
المراه والرجل والعلاقه الحميميه ما فيش
احد بيتكلم عن ان ربنا قال قل اعماله
فسيرى الله عملكم ورسوله والمؤمنون ما فيش
احد قال ان ربنا قال من شاء فليؤمن ومن
شاء فليكفر ما حدش بيقول ان ربنا قال لا
اكرهها في الدين كل حاجه بقى في ناس
بتعتبر نفسها بتنصب نفسها قال لها همم
فيعني الاله دي يعني لازم المراه ترجع
قدامه ده ده تماما يعني استاذه فريده يمكن
انت اول واحده اعرفها تقول انا كبيره قوي
في السن
ههه معلش ما انا كبيره اعمل ايه انا على
فكره بحب الصراحه
العمر كله ان شاء الله يا رب
بس يعني حضرتك
ربنا عارفه
كم
اقول لك وما تقوليش لحد حاضر انا ماشيه في
ال 85
اه بس اقول لك على حكايه ظريفه كده في
دقيقه واحده لما كنت في باريس اخر مره قبل
الكرونه فديت للراجل بتاع
الباسبور بتاعي وضحك ليه في حاجه تضحك
يعني قال لي لا ما تعمليش سنك ما تديش سنك
يعني فانا كانوع من البيت
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
ان شاء الله بصحه وعافيه كانت معنا فريده
عضو البرلمان المصري شكرا لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
نرجع الى اخبار المنصات والتكنولوجيا وخبر
الان عن شركه متى اللى كمان تصدرت الاخبار
والعناوين من بعد تداول وانتشار معلومات
انه الشركه راح تبدا تخفيض كبير في اعداد
موظفيها لكن ما تم ذكر العدد ولا النسبه
وبحسب معلومات
في عمليه التسريح هذه بتعتبر اول تقليص
واسع النطاق لشركه من وقت تاسيسها من 18
سنه وذكر تقرير الصحيفه انه شركه متى وظفت
خلال العامين الماضيين اكثر من 20,000
موظف وانخفض سهم متالي 70% بسبب ارتفاع
معدل الانفاق وهذا الشيء اجبر الرئيس
التنفيذي لها مركز انه يتخذ قرار التسريح
وحسب المعلومات المتداوله في ماركت على
تواجد اشخاص في الشركه ما لهم داعي
وبالتالي راح تنفذ متى خطتها في تسريحهم
وخفض الانفاق ل 10% والتركيز على
الاستثمارات الصغيره ذات الاولويه العاليه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدين احنا وصلنا للختام حلقه اليوم انا
اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله